own mark meredith reporting live from
the white house with the latest this
meeting definitely going to happen today
dana it sure looks like it doesn't look
like the winter weather is going to
impact it the president still expected
to meet with some senate republicans
here at the white house
later on this afternoon this group of
republicans proposing their own coven 19
economic stimulus package
among those people we're expecting here
at the white house today susan collins
of maine rob portman of ohio
and mitt romney of utah the lawmakers
sending the president a letter over the
weekend saying
we recognize your calls for unity and
want to work in good
faith with your administration to meet
the health economic
and societal challenges of the kovic
crisis now they are proposing a number
of things here including a 600 billion
dollar overall package
that would have about a thousand dollars
for stimulus checks but they would be
phased out by certain incomes
it would also extend enhancing the
federal unemployment benefit
and offer more money for food assistance
programs
we think there's a lot here to work for
to work with we hope
we finally start getting that bipartisan
and with the white house negotiation
so far we've not received it now this
proposal spends a lot less than what
democrats have been pushing they've been
going for that 1.9 trillion dollar
economic
economic stimulus package the white
house says it wants to hear what these
lawmakers have to say
but senate democrats are less believing
that this is actually something that
will work when it comes to a smaller
package
and trying to jump start the economy
we hope that we can move forward in a
bipartisan way with our republican
colleagues cooperating
but we need big bold action and if we
can't move forward
with them we'll have to do it on our own
getting the job done in a big bold way
is the number one priority
now remember that democrats hold a
narrow majority in both the house and
the senate so getting any legislation
passed solely on party lines
is not always guaranteed so they may
have to the white house may have to rely
on more republicans
in order to get a bill done quickly as
we expect that meeting will be happening
in the five o'clock hour cameras
expected to be brought in dana
and while i mentioned the snow is not
impacting that meeting it has changed
the president's schedule
he won't be going over to the state
department later on today and it looks
like the senate is going to wait another
day to confirm his
homeland security secretary nominee and
dana that could impact the president's
plans to talk about immigration tomorrow
we'll find out a little bit later on
today mark meredith with a full update
thank you so much we want to bring in
martissanamo
alithee moe and mark on monday fox news
contributors gentlemen good morning to
both of you
unity is out the door good morning or
was it even in the room at first mark
what do you think
well first of all i'm ready for this
segment because i've got my banana so
i'm
fired up and ready to go look if joe
biden does not work with these
republicans and make this proposal
the basis of a bipartisan covet relief
package then his inaugural address about
unity and bipartisanship was a big lie
uh he this is the test of biden's uh
commitment to unity and bipartisanship
he has 10 republicans coming to him
willing to support 600 billion covered
relief packages on top of the 900
billion already passed just a few weeks
ago so 1.5 trillion dollars not
nothing to sneeze at a lot of
republicans don't think we need another
coveted relief package right now
they're providing 10 votes which means a
bipartisan filibuster-proof majority
for this package because you need 60
votes to break a filibuster they're
providing the 10 republicans to do that
if joe biden looks at that and says
sorry folks not good enough
i'm going to ram through my almost 2
trillion dollar package on
just with democratic votes using the
reconciliation process
then bipartisanship is dead and all the
rhetoric about unity and cooperation and
compromise is a big lie
so this is a big test for joe biden
today over the weekend as i read all the
coverage
mo i felt like you could feel a
noticeable shift in the tone of coverage
to the point uh that mark is just making
here
let me listen to two things here's brian
dees he's the president's nec director
national economic council director
on this idea go ahead we're certainly
open to input from
anywhere where we can find a
constructive idea to make this package
as effective as possible
but the president is uncompromising when
it comes to the speed that we need to
act at
to address this crisis however bernie
sanders
he's got to say listen to this
we all want bipartisanship and i think
you're going to see more of it
as we move down the pipe we are going to
look forward to working with republicans
but right now this country faces
an unprecedented set of crises
and mow the third leg of the democratic
stool in this case joe manchin listen to
what he had to say
um when joe when kamal harris the vice
president came to his state or what you
know the media in his state to try to
pressure him he said
i saw the interview i couldn't believe
it no one called me about it
we're going to try to find a bipartisan
pathway forward but we need to work
together
that's not a way of working together and
he's talking about internal democratic
issues
mo tell us what you think
um look i don't think this is an either
or right i mean
the legislative process is a give and
take and i'm just happy to see
washington getting back to that give and
take with lots of sharp elbows
which which many of us have felt uh
throughout our careers but the president
put forward a really bold
proposal now he's about to sit down with
a bipartisan group of senators
and see where they meet i suspect they
will meet i
you know i i i don't disagree with a lot
of what mark said but when mark
said that there are a lot of republicans
out there who don't believe we need
anything i i think there's a lot of
people out there good
hard-working americans who are
struggling who would agree that we need
something i'm glad to see that there's a
bipartisan group of senators who believe
we need something they're going to sit
down today let's see where we meet
it'll hopefully be more than the 600
billion it will probably
less than 1.9 trillion
but i agree with the president that we
need to move fast on this so let's see
what the process is
you know if you didn't have this group
of republicans coming up with this plan
who knows when there would be a meeting
because there was nothing on the
schedule until they went public with it
yeah so so joe biden introduced his 1.9
trillion dollars
without talking to a single republican
without talking to recovering the
democrats on capitol hill he just
proposed
what he wanted and put it out there okay
fine so that's a starting point but the
idea that you're going to
ram that through using reconciliation
and then republicans can come along or
not
is not bipartisanship and what what he
needs to realize is what's the x factor
here as you mentioned is joe manchin so
this this proposal came out of a
bipartisan group led by susan collins
and joe manchin joe manchin
is not simply sitting on the sidelines
he helped craft this for this proposal
that's being presented to
uh to to uh the president right now so
you know
he can he's staying on the sidelines i
think partly because
he wants joe biden to make the choice
for bipartisanship on his own rather
than being forced into it
but you know when bernie sanders says we
need to push forward we need with 1.9
trillion we've got the votes well
let me give you some a math lesson 50
democrats minus joe manchin is 49 votes
and 49 votes gets you
uh bupkus in the united states senate
sign of things to come though when
with margins this type
uh yeah look i think there's going to
with margins this height
and mark and i have agreed on this in
the past i i think that you're going to
see
a move towards that middle group of
senators people like mansion
cinema on the democratic side people
like romney and collins and
others on the republican side they are
going to have a lot of sway over the
legislative process moving forward
and so everybody whether it's mitch
mcconnell or
the white house uh ought to pay special
attention to that group
pay attention to chuck schumer's words
on sunday bold chains we're going to get
that no matter what
gentlemen thank you nice to see on a
monday morning mo and mark
thanks